how's he doing I know he's got to take
care of what yeah there's one thing are
you still drinking Huggies but for my
culture
I drink Huggies Huggies and eat welfare
cheese oh wait well run right King
Huggies you made up you said you what
you I couldn't do it I would I try to go
cold turkey but I couldn't do it can you
just back it up for a second cuz Huggies
Huggies these welfare Jews it's like
sugar water that little plastic barrel
with aluminum foil and you shouldn't be
drinking those now you're grown man but
I got it go Google will fetch government
cheese but you are you have Walmart
money baby Tracy you're wearing a
jewelry counter around your neck exactly
you're telling us that you're drinking
huggy you needed government check these
cost 25 cents well back in the day they
did some things don't go away
[Laughter]
Tracy that's not good for your kidney
right now for not some people you just
can't say how god I like the boy in the
plastic bubble I I don't remember how he
went out in a body did he go out my
favorite movie is day of the dolphin
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the film the film
is called day of the dolphins
[Applause]
set gorge see Scott 19 I'm gonna pass
1975 yeah remember what he said PI's
said go remember the dolphins started
talking to her I say not started crying
I cried out for that and Kramer vs
Kramer okay okay okay if anyone wants a
transcript we'll get you a transcript
and it will all make sense with
footnotes and everything it's all gonna
be laid out with all these references
mean what men want is in theaters this
Friday tried to be handsome Tracy Morgan